MS. ♪ ♪
>> Laura: MR. PRESIDENT I KNOW
YOU WERE CLOSE TO THE QUEEN AND
SHE HAS A LOT OF AFFECTION FOR
YOU.
>> President Trump: WE HAVE A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP.
>> Laura: WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
GIVE HER ANY ADVICE FOR THE
ROGUE ROYALS?
WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE?
A LOT OF TOE MOLD.
YOU'VE BEEN SO GOOD AT KEEPING
YOUR KIDS TOGETHER IN A
CLOSE-KNIT FAMILY.
>> President Trump: I THINK IT
IS SAD.
I DO.
SHE IS A GREAT WOMAN.
I SAT WITH HER.
I WAS SUPPOSED TO BE WITH HER
FOR 15 MINUTES BUT I STAYED AN
HOUR AND A HALF.
BY THE WAY, I GOT KILLED BY THE
PRESS.
THE PRESS HAD NO, NO, HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE THERE AND THAT
WAS RUDE.
WHAT A GREAT TIME.
WE HAD DINNER.
THE COUNTRY WAS HONORED.
I SAT WITH HER FOR A LONG TIME.
SHE WAS SMILING AND LAUGHING THE
WHOLE TIME.
>> Laura: SHE HAS THE
TRADITION OF THE MONARCHY AND
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> President Trump: WE HAVE A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP.
I THINK THIS WAS A PLAIN SIGHT.
SHE WAS BLINDSIDED BY THIS, THE
WHOLE SITUATION.
I THINK IT IS TOO BAD.
BUT, YOU KNOW, SHE HAS BEEN THE
CLAIM, AN ALL-TIME RECORD
APPEARED FROM THE TIME SHE WAS
25 AND NOW 94.
SHE HAS NEVER MADE A MISTAKE, IF
YOU LOOK.
SHE'S HAD A FLAWLESS TIME.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK KERRY
SHOULD GO BACK, COME BACK?
>> President Trump: I DON'T
WANT TO GET INTO THE WHOLE
THING.
BUT I FIND IT, I HAVE SUCH
RESPECT FOR THE QUEEN AND I
DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD BE
HAPPENING TO HER.
>> Laura: AOC ANNOUNCED TODAY
AND THIS IS THE FINAL QUESTION,
PRESIDENT, NO POLITICS AT THE
UPCOMING OLYMPICS, NEW POLICY BY
THE ATHLETES.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE THAT
EXTENDED TO THE UNITED STATES
WHERE POLITICS STAY OUT OF
SPORTS?
I KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO THE BIG
LSU GAME.
>> President Trump: I AM AND I
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR GETTING THE
OLYMPICS.
THE OLYMPICS COMING TO
LOS ANGELES.
IT WAS COLD BUT THE MAYOR AND HE
SAID CAN YOU DO US A FAVOR BY
PRESIDENT-ELECT?
AND I WORKED VERY HARD AND GOT
THE OLYMPICS.
WE HAVE THE WORLD COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES.
I DON'T KNOW.
I GUESS YOU CAN SAY NO POLITICS,
BUT PEOPLE ARE TOP ON POLITICS.
I THINK I HAVE MADE POLITICS
SOMEWHAT MORE EXCITING.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WOULD BE
DEAD RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: WHAT ARE THEY GOING
TO DO WITHOUT YOU?
>> President Trump:
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WOULD BE
OUT OF BUSINESS.
I HATE TO SAY BUT CABLE